good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson said happy Friday what a day and
it started on the weirdest possible note
if you tuned into the Today Show this
morning looking for the usual funny cat
videos and trans friendly salad recipes
you may have been surprised to find
actual news being committed on your
screen in place of the segment you
expected to see fit and sexy over 70.
there was NBC News correspondent Miguel
almaguir letting you know that actually
that assault on Paul Pelosi in San
Francisco that you read about last week
that story was a whole lot Stranger than
you ever imagined
according to Al mcgear citing several
law enforcement sources with direct
knowledge it was Paul Pelosi who opened
the door for police when they arrived
now you'll remember that authorities had
previously told us that the Intruder
David depape had broken into Paul
Pelosi's bedroom on the third floor of
the house and woken him up yet somehow
both Pelosi and to paper on the ground
floor by the time police got there
moreover according to Alma gear Pelosi
and de Pape had been together in the
house for at least half an hour and yet
strangely they both seemed fine
with police president Al mcgear reported
Paul Pelosi quote did not immediately
declare an emergency or leave his home
instead he quote walked back several
feet toward the assailant and away from
police
what
Paul Pelosi walked away from the police
and toured David de Pape what could
possibly explain behavior like that and
what were the two doing for the 30
minutes before police arrived
under normal circumstances we wouldn't
want to know Paul Pelosi's personal life
is his business it's not our business
we've got nothing against the guy we
believe in privacy
but unfortunately for Paul Pelosi
there's an election coming next week and
his wife's allies immediately
politicized the assault against him they
tried to tell us that David depape a
homeless illegal alien nudist drug
addict who had a BLM flag hanging near
the broken school bus that he lives in
was actually a right-wing Hitman
inspired by Q determined to act out the
violence of January 6 in Nancy Pelosi's
own home
they told us that like we'd believe it
then the president of the United States
went on television and said it again
it's laughably absurd Russia bombed its
own pipeline okay but they said it and
they're still saying it then out of
nowhere Comes The Today Show the head
baton twirler and the Democratic party's
media Pep Squad and completely probably
unintentionally blows up their lie
after watching Al mcgear's story in the
Today Show this morning you could only
conclude as Elon Musk put it there's a
tiny possibility there might be more to
this story than meets the eye you think
and now we know for a fact that there is
more to the story because NBC News has
Jeffrey epsteined the entire thing NBC
deleted Alma gear story both from its
website and from Twitter
why'd they do that well obviously they
did it because the report was true
there's no question when was the last
time you saw someone punished for lying
no one's ever punished for lying you can
lie all you want
what you can't do is tell the truth
about something important
that's dangerous you will be punished if
you do that and many are punished in
case you haven't noticed
so just for fun we called over to NBC
news today we want to get their
explanation for why they censored their
own story
but mostly for being honest we just
wanted to rub their noses in the fact
that they're not journalists at all
they're obedient little throne-sniffing
servants to the party in power
predictably NBC News refused to tell us
what was wrong with their own story but
of course we already knew what was wrong
with it Nancy Pelosi didn't like it that
was the problem
and I suppose he did appreciate the
story that NBC News ran entitled The GOP
has Paul Pelosi's blood on its hands
that story remains on the NBC website
tonight it meets their quote standards
so what are we watching here well lying
obviously
but not the usual kind of line normal
people lie in a very recognizable way
they're human beings they have
consciences they feel guilty about lying
so they don't go all the way they shade
the truth
did you eat these cookies you ask your
five-year-old
I had one he'll say look at you
nervously he's lying but he's doing it
to the minimum extent he feels he has to
but if you ask a sociopath the same
question you'll get a very different
answer
did you eat these cookies you'll ask no
he'll replied looking you straight in
the face and smiling faintly you ate
them
that's not shading the truth that's
inverting the truth
scary and you're seeing a lot of it
lately
John fetterman won The View today for
example the one thing everyone knows
about John fetterman is that in may he
suffered serious brain damage from a
stroke he can now barely speak that's
true it's obvious there's no debate
about it now if you live in Pennsylvania
you may vote for John fetterman on
Tuesday anyway depending upon how
attached you are to late term abortion
but no matter how you vote with or
against you can't argue that John
fetterman quote looks and sounds great
because by any measure he does not at
all
but that's exactly what ABC hosts argued
today watch this
I think you look and sound great so last
week let me ask you this uh you and Dr
Oz faced off in your first televised
debate and you said quote it wasn't
exactly easy I think it was an
incredibly courageous and brave thing
for you to show what healing from a
stroke looks like that's incredibly
Brave on the other hand Dr Oz a cardiac
surgeon in my view came off as a bully
does any of this surprise you a man with
a Harvard master's degree do you think
the people of Pennsylvania Saw what they
needed to see from you to gain their
vote
yeah I I really believe that it
certainly wasn't an even an even event
for me without a doubt
John fetterman you look and sound great
really ABC lady have you had a stroke
too
how stupid do you think your audience is
pretty stupid apparently this same liar
described fetterman's Senate debate
performance the one you saw as quote
incredibly courageous and brave like he
was on the bin Laden raid instead of
drooling on a stage in Harrisburg in
case you've forgotten what she was
referring to here's what it looked like
you're running for a seat that could
decide the balance of power in
Washington what qualifies you to be a
U.S senator you have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody
hi good night everybody
that's not incredibly courageous it's
incredibly cruel John fetterman's wife
ought to be shunned by decent people for
allowing that to happen she knew her
husband's condition she just wants the
power it's disgusting and keep in mind
that's how John fetterman talks with the
help of a computer we got a glimpse of
his talking machine today it's the size
of an iron lung
better man who's recovering from a
stroke in May used a closed captioning
device during the interview with the
stenographer typing out the questions in
real time
again just like the question of what
Paul Pelosi was doing at two in the
morning with an illegal alien nudist we
would be just as happy in fact very
happy to ignore this whole thing we
don't want to talk about John
fetterman's stroke it's awful it's
depressing
John Federman should have dropped out of
the race in May with the encouragement
of his loving wife which apparently
doesn't have
but instead they're pushing him the
Democratic party is pushing him to run
for the Senate despite his inability to
speak and they're doing that because
they want power and for the rest of us
that means we are now required to
pretend that this sad brain damage guy
is actually incredibly Brave and
impressive
in other words they're demanding that we
ignore what we can see with our eyes
that's called the big lie
and four days before the midterm
elections it's everywhere
here's Joy Reid of MSNBC telling you
that inflation is not real now you may
think you may imagine that you're paying
more for spaghetti and two by fours and
heating oil oh no that's the figment of
your imagination in fact it's a
diabolical psyop engineered by the
information Warfare division of the
Republican party in Washington
watch this the only people I ever heard
here use the word inflation are
journalists
um and economists right so that is not
part of the normal lexicon of the way
people talk so it's interesting that
Republicans are doing something they
don't normally do right which is not
used com the common tongue right not
used just common English to sort of use
do on their campaigns like they're doing
with prime but what they've done is
they've taught people the word inflation
right most people who would have never
used that word ever in their lives are
using it now because they've been taught
it including on TV including in
newspapers they've been taught this word
someday we're going to do a recurring
segment called guest Joy reads IQ
that'll be fun what they've done says
the Harvard lady what they've done is
they've taught people the word inflation
there you have it ladies and gentlemen
the Republican Party running around
teaching people words even three
syllable words
inflation inflation
scary next some of these Maga people
will be reading and writing their own
names on legal documents and God knows
what else
stop them before they bring literacy to
the population
before you know it people will start to
believe that crime is real and for the
record it's not
but there's a major concern surrounding
the racist rhetoric that often goes hand
in glove with the law and order messages
Republicans are pulling out all
concerned about voter safety they're
they just want to keep voters scared
they have now turned to a strategy that
sensationalizes crime that weaponizes
crime and that racializes crime the
other guys play the crime card uh
relentlessly and shame shame shamelessly
it's got racial elements to it let's
just call that for what it is the type
of crime that scares Republican and
independent voters the most to make them
believe that crime is skyrocketing that
America is a hell hole and the thing is
it works dystopian nakedly racist video
preferably grainy security cam footage
featuring almost exclusively black
people committing crime in big cities
see that's the thing you know what
they're doing do you know what they're
doing
these racists they're weaponizing crime
it's not the guy with the weapon who's
the problem the one stealing your purse
or raping you or breaking into your
house or carjacking you with the kids in
the back no no that's not the weapon
that we need to worry about the weapon
is you're noticing that it's happening
and in case you don't believe that we
have statistics and they appeared the
other day on CNN CNN ran a report on FBI
crime stats showing that crime is down
see crime is down these are numbers
kind of forgot to mention that the FBI
report they cited left out 40 percent of
major cities in the United States
including the two biggest New York and
Los Angeles
[Laughter]
just kind of forgot that oh except for
the population centers but you know in
Bangor and Great Falls totally fine it's
totally fine
so again this is not a small lie not a
small lie it's a big lie the big lie
it's a phrase they use of course they do
they're also denying there's anything
wrong with our Southern border there's
nothing wrong with our Southern border
there's no Invasion five million people
five million friends more for dinner not
a big deal
and by the way if you've got video of it
it's probably fake actually we do here
it is
clearly this is Major news this is a
former president of the United States
getting subpoenaed while this huge news
event was breaking what was Fox News
airing crime crime crime crime inflation
immigration that's all they do all day
every day just going right to the fears
of the American people we saw JD Vance
harping on the issue of crime and talk
and linking it to things like illegal
immigration those are the types of
issues the things that drive fear
they're just coming straight out and
especially during election time we see
it's the Caravans again it's the fear of
immigrants they were scaring Suburban
white women with Caravans coming to
their neighborhood you turn on Fox News
any time of day any day of the week
there are three messages on repeat the
Border crisis crime On The Rise and
inflation
why aren't they talking about climate
change haven't they seen the greater
videos climate change is what matters
instead they're talking about their
country their stupid country it's
because five million people should
you're racist if you notice
again nothing you just heard refutes in
any way the facts that Fox News
puts on a loop
what an address is is you
and the person who attacks is you
because you dared to notice
shut up
you're not allowed to notice and don't
you dare vote against it
so if the many lies they're pushing
maybe the most bewildering of all is the
idea that you can destroy democracy by
voting really we're under the impression
destroyed democracy with like artillery
or by changing the population of your
country by opening the borders thereby
watering down the voting power of the
population it's citizens that might be
destroying democracy but no now we've
learned that the real Attack on
democracy is electoral Disobedience
watch this
make no mistake
democracy is in the ballot for all of us
democracy is on the ballot democracy is
on the ballot think about this democracy
is on the ballot democracy is actually
on the ballot democracy is on the ballot
democracy is on the ballot and democracy
is on the ballot do you believe that
democracy is on the ballot in Utah
it is on the ballot democracy is on the
ballot this year in America somebody's
got to tell both what they need to hear
which is that democracy is on the ballot
all right and this is ultimately a new
show we have our opinions but we it's
also incumbent on us to check the facts
we have a sample ballot here and we're
checking and it turns out democracy is
not on the ballot
um they're actually names of candidates
who are on the ballot and you get to
choose one as a voter the one who best
represents you and you get to choose any
candidate you want because it's a
democracy meaning you run the government
because it's your country so no
democracy is not on the ballot and of
course they knew that what they're
really telling you is that the threat to
democracy is voters don't you dare
destroy this beautiful representative
government by asking it to represent you
how dare you
democracy means supporting Joe Biden in
anything less than that is insurrection
that's the script they're reading and
the amazing thing is some of the more
feeble-minded among them actually seem
to believe it so Michael beschlas for
example best loss is living proof that
you don't have to pass an IQ test to
become a historian you just have to call
yourself one I'm a historian Michael
beschlas so they hauled in beschlas the
other day from semi-retirement to
ruminate about democracy and they
expected him to say democracy is on the
ballot
and he may have said that but as he got
going he lost control of himself watch
this
and a historian 50 years from now if
historians are allowed to ride in this
country and if there are still free
publishing houses and a free press which
I'm not certain of but if that is true a
historian will say what was at stake
tonight and this week was the fact
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed we're on
the edge of a brutal authoritarian
system and it could be a week away
a week away what
we don't know where Michael Besh loss is
broadcasting from it didn't look like a
bunker looked like a French country
kitchen that his decorator put together
but whatever hope he's stockpiling
low carb pasta because it could be
it could be a dark tomorrow now keep in
mind this is the guy who's advising Joe
Biden on extremism but needless as he
does not regard himself as an extremist
quote if you vote Republican your
children will be arrested and killed
that's his campaign slogan it's not
quite as reassuring as say a chicken in
every pot or even hope and change
but at this point Democrats are out of
Hope and above all they fear change they
want things to say exactly the way they
are unfortunately for them Blake Masters
May soon bring change to Washington we
hope he does he's running for Senate
from the state of Arizona subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight